if I could redesign the world what i
would do is ask this very question to
children and youth living all around the
world in community centers in schools in
refugee camps in fact this is what i've
done as part of the youth task force
over the past year we've engaged
thousands of youth from all around the
world honest Harry question and
presented their ideas in Davos at the
World Economic Forum and as contribution
to this global redesign summit I would
also like to share that I believe some
key messages we need to focus on in
redesigning institutions are one that
education should really have the student
centered learning approach we really
need to think about what motivates and
inspires learners so that they feel
empowered in the process of their own
education and to in the area of health
care what i feel is protocol is to take
a prevention focus how can we actually
promote a culture of healthy choices
starting in our youth and adolescents
and the third key thing is really
looking at how decision-making processes
are designed in a way that is inclusive
with dignity at the center and at the
core and in my ten years of experience
with taking it global I've done a lot of
work and outreach consulting with youth
and trying to help youth voices really
influence decision makers and I'm
excited that's happened here in doha